foreign
next is Karina in Boise hey Karina
welcome to the show
hi thank you yeah absolutely how can we
help
so last week me and my fiance broke up
because we couldn't decide on finances
and also more importantly we couldn't
decide on how to inherit our kids
he has two boys and I have one son and I
have a paid for house and I make a bit
more money than him
and he has a house with some liquidy in
it but he has a roommate on the title
and mortgage because they invest it
together
and then
um so I am I am Christian and I know God
wants us to put our spouse before our
children but I think in our arguments I
was just having such a hard time
and um you know I haven't
I haven't been with my fiance but it's
for a week but just moving forward with
him or without him I need to figure it
out for the next time that this comes up
about and you know figure out how to how
to deal with it you know do you guys
share children children are your
children from different folks you share
them what what's the situation
oh yeah he has two boys with his first
wife okay and I have a son and I pretty
much raised him alone
um his father was not involved okay so
gotcha okay yeah and what was the
disagreement about Karina
so I think
um I it all started when I mentioned to
him that when I moved into my house
which is paid off
um I I wanted to leave his as an
inheritance to my son because
I think
um I sacrificed a lot of quality time
when my son was little
um because I was going to school for
engineering and I was single and I was
working so I didn't get to spend that
quality time with him and when I finally
got that stability I wanted to give it
to him kind of to make up for what I
couldn't do before so it's really
emotional for me to talk about finances
and um my my ex-fiance he wasn't
understanding that and um and I to this
point I get it like
um your spouse should come first but in
terms of finances I'm just having a hard
time dealing with that yeah did you
um did you initiate the breakup or did
he
um it was just kind of
Mutual we we just kind of got tired of
talking about different scenarios and
how we can make it work
and we both argued our points like I
know he wants to protect his children
and um and I want to protect my son in
terms of you know what we have
established already
um so
so what's your question what's your
question for us specifically
like how
how can how do you
go about finances in like a second
relationship when you already bring in
children
do you
like because how old are the kids this
inherit them so do you just not get
married yeah my son is 21. okay and then
his kids he has a 13 year old and a 15
year old okay so no I I I let Rachel
take the bigger Crux of the relationship
and money but he's 21 and he has a 15
year old
um no my son is 21. my fiance is 40. oh
my gosh I'm so sorry I thought you meant
he has more than he as in your fiancee
I'm sorry I apologize yeah I I just
wanna I wanna point out something that's
come up twice in the conversation with
us and I just want to get that out of
the way and let Rachel kind of help you
on this and and I can weigh in on the
mayor stuff too but
this idea that the Bible says that you
you value your spouse of your kids this
idea that that means you disinherit your
son no no no no no no
this this is all going to fall under the
same umbrella that Rachel's gonna advise
you on on y'all being on the same page
and it doesn't matter if the kids are
coming in from previous relationships or
not but no no under no scenario are you
going to disavow or as you're saying
disinherit your son uh that that's not
part of the equation and if that's part
of the conversation it's not healthy and
you did the right thing by walking
yeah and Karina for you as a mom
um because I can only imagine the
sacrifices that you made when he was
little and that's where a lot of this
emotion is coming from
and so I feel like I would I would I
would kind of challenge you to say you
know this is a symbol this house is a
symbol of your hard work you feeling
guilty probably a level of mom guilt of
leaving your son when he was younger and
it's excruciating you know when I have
to leave my kids I had a four-year-old
crying in the garage when I pulled out
to come to this show like it's it's not
it's not fun like it is it is hard as a
mom
uh for those working and that you're
like oh and so you as a single mom
especially
went through so much Karina so much in
order to have this but I I would I would
just challenge you not that this would
change your decision but I want you to
if you can separate this house and what
you did for your son and the
relationship you have with your son this
house has become a symbol
um and I don't want it to be the make or
break breaking point for you in the
future with relationships and I and I
understand that it's to protect this for
your son
um but just as a mom I don't want you to
carry that burden of still feeling like
I have to I have to make up for what I
did because Karina you did what you had
to do you were a single mom and that's
that was the situation you were in and
so that you were not a bad mom for doing
this so giving your house a son or not
giving your your son a house or not does
it make you a good or bad mom
um so I want you to kind of separate
that that language in your head because
I feel like that's Twisted into this
decision does that make sense
yes
um because I I under and I and I and I
applaud you for
um being so protective of it because
again I I I hear what you walk through
with it so it makes sense but I also
don't want this house to be the symbol
of what I did and I feel bad and now I
have to make it up to my son because you
know what your son wants Karina he wants
you and and and if he wants his mom to
be happy if this man that you love
um your your ex-fiance you know if there
if if that is a relationship that is
good for you and it is healthy
um and you guys can find the way to to
reconcile these two things or this thing
of The Inheritance which is a big deal
but but also at the end of the day like
there's a point two of companionship and
love in a marriage
um that's the question I have Karina and
pardon me for I was trying to listen are
you guys on the same page with debt and
everything else
or is there also some some separation in
the way he sees money and debt and all
that stuff because you've done
everything the right way
where are you guys on the rest of the
stuff the rest of the money stuff
she she's good with money and um
yeah he's very smart with money and I
don't think there is an issue there
I think it's just more about
combining combining households and
um you know is he on the same page with
you remember being in one right but let
me ask you this is he on the same page
in relation to debt that's yes or no
yes okay is he is he also on the same
page that when we come together as a
married couple we combine our finances
yes he is more for that than me
he he said that we should combine
everything
and um at the end of the day we just
split it up like when we both passed
away we just split it up evenly between
all our kids okay all right all right so
I'm the one that's kind of like selfish
because I'm I'm like I'm bringing in
more and he has two kids and I have one
kid yeah but Rachel's right I hope you
heard Rachel uh I'm telling you she's
right so I I got to tell you I'm taking
a little bit different attack here I
think you guys need to have a nice
dinner
and I think you guys need to sit down
and get this hashed out and say what
really matters and let's look at the big
picture and you're gonna have to let go
of some stuff I love Rachel's advice
there I don't know I want to see her I
want to see her give this a chance I
know because I feel like this is just
about the investment through the
internet when it becomes this this thing
and we don't want our stuff to own us
and at that point it's owning a part of
you for good reason I understand it but
I want you to have freedom from that and
I think it's attached to that Mom Gail
Karina that I really want you to think
through so thank you for calling I hope
that helps and and you know I hope you
guys
um Can can go the way that you need to
go whether it's together or separate
thanks for calling